premier minister reisen heute jetzt
gerade in diesen momenten ins umkämpfte
kiew um dort auch dann präsent wie lenz
geht zu treffen auf den weg haben sich
gemacht der premierminister von
tschechien von slowenien und von polen
wollen dann heute dort ein zeichen
setzen machen sich auf mit dem zug der
zeit in die hauptstadt der ukraine
was für eine friedensmission was für ein
signal von den dreien das ist europa das
ist die eu von ihrer besten seite über
dieses treffen über diesen besuch in der
kriegs hauptstadt in kiew berichten
gleich unsere reporter paul ronzheimer
hans jörg vehlewald alle dort sie diese
reise aktuell dieser drei
regierungschefs begleiten wir schauen
auf das was sie heute wissen müssen über
den ukraine krieg
erfassen als einmal für sie zusammen was
müssen sie heute wissen es gab wieder
mehrere explosionen in kiew gleichzeitig
eine protestaktion gesehen live dort
immer russischen fernsehen und jetzt in
diesen minuten machen sich drei uhr
regierungschef auf den weg nach kiew
genau dort schalten wir sind so paul
ronzheimer seit wochen dort im
kriegsgebiet heute morgen uns
zugeschaltet dort vor den zerbombten
wohnblöcken und auch jetzt wieder bei
uns paul und von dir wollen wir
natürlich wissen wie fasst man dort in
der ukraine diese der historische
friedensmission diesem so
symbolträchtigen besuch auf
deswegen natürlich begrüßt aber man muss
gleichzeitig sagen die menschen hier auf
der straße die haben andere sorgen wir
haben angst die haben angst getötet zu
werden sie haben angst vor weiteren
bomben sie haben angst dass dieser krieg
einfach nie wieder aufhört das ist ein
bisschen das gefühl vor allem weil es
sich in der hauptstadt so eskaliert hat
weil hier mittlerweile jeder spürt dass
es so nahe ist und wenn man sich
anschaut wie die debatten auch laufen
die politischen debatten dann gab es mal
hoffnung dann wieder keine hoffnung dann
wieder
dieses gefühl jedes haus kann getroffen
werden so wie heute morgen und was ich
höre aus meinen quellen den politischen
quellen mit denen ich gesprochen habe im
laufe des tages gibt es große sorgen
dass die angriffe schlimmer werden
können und zwar morgen bereits es gibt
deswegen eine ausgangssperre verhängt
worden ist ab heute abend dann auch
morgen den ganzen tag über normalerweise
beginnt diese ausnahme sperre acht uhr
abends bis 7 uhr morgens und jetzt soll
sie ab heute abend dann auch den ganzen
tag morgen gelten also man hat erneut
das muss man sagen denn diese sorge gibt
es bereits seit wochen die große sorge
dass es zu einem großangriff kommen kann
auch viel leider überhaupt keine guten
nachrichten von dir gerade paul
ronzheimer in kiew direkt und trotzdem
dieser winziger hoffnungsschimmer
das war eine fast naive idee von unserem
gemeinsamen kollegen peter tiede die hat
er uns gegenüber geäußert vor 14 tagen
ungefähr lasst doch alle staats und
regierungschefs im moment in die ukraine
fahren oder fliegen nach kiew dann
traute er sich nicht neue bomben zu
schicken jetzt machen sich eben diese
drei regierungschefs auf den weg ist das
zu kindlich zu naiv gedacht oder gibt es
tatsächlich hoffnung dass wenn alle
zusammenhalten sich so menschlich zeigen
dorthin reisen dass dann die
bombardements zumindest kurzzeitig
aufhören könnten
kein möglicherweise steht es sogar im
zusammenhang mit dieser sorge von der
ich gerade berichtet habe mit dieser
sorge dass es zu einem großangriff kommt
das kann ich aus polnischer und
tschechischer sicht nicht bestätigen
darüber habe ich mit niemandem dort
gesprochen aber es ist ja schon
interessant dass ist diese warnung gibt
gleichzeitig die sorge dass es morgens
zu einem großangriff kommen und dann
gleichzeitig heute bekannt wird dass die
regierungschefs hierher fahren das ist
ein wahnsinnig symbolisches und tolles
zeichen finde ich das wirklich große
respekt verdient und was natürlich den
ukrainern war sich nahe geht und diese
unterstützung das ist es die sie
einfordern und die sich auch zu recht
einfordern das haben wir auch schon
präsident zielinski gehört wir sehen
hinter die die stadt im sonnenschein und
sie macht fast seinen friedlichen
eindruck und widerspricht natürlich den
bildern die wir uns heute vormittag
geliefert heißt wie diesem völlig
zerstörten wohnblock und gleichzeitig
die angst vor einem großangriff es
irgend einen eindruck darüber wie man
sich derzeit in kiew rüstet wird das was
mal man mag jetzt in den nächsten 36
stunden
die stimmung ist wesentlich nervöser
geworden das merkt man an den vielen
checkpoints in der stadt dort sehe ich
anti panzer minen die dort bereit stehen
also für die möglichkeit dass man dann
dort straßen verlassen muss vermied man
sie wenn russische panzer dort
tatsächlich durchfahren sollten aber
daran will auch irgendwie dann doch
wieder niemand denken und dieses gefühl
dass sie tatsächlich hier irgendwann
hinter mir da sieht man das
außenministerium nicht weit entfernt in
den präsidentenpalast dass sie dort
irgendwann stehen könnten drin sein
könnten da wo jetzt noch selensky in
diesen minuten vielleicht läuft er
bewegt sich ja an verschiedenen orten
aber da wo ich ihn interviewt zwischen
diesen sandsäcken wo die ukrainische
flagge ist dass da irgendwann die
russische sein könnte daran will heute
und insgesamt in der ukraine niemand
glauben von daher ist es immer eine
mischung aus hoffnung und sorgen dank
accounts haben wir unser bild reporter
in kiew aktuell vielen dank für den
moment also paulis dort wo im moment
drei regierungschefs aus europa hin
reisen nämlich von slowenien von der von
tschechien und von polen sie haben sich
überlegt jetzt in dieser immer
komplizierter werdenden situation auch
für kiew dorthin zu fahren ihre
solidarität zu zeigen wir gehen nach
warschau zu unserem kollegen hans jörg
vehlewald der das sozusagen aus der
polnischen perspektive betrachtet das
klingt nach einer ganz ja großartigen
idee sich auf den weg zu machen man kann
die füße nicht stillhalten man muss
jetzt dorthin man muss zur see lance
gehen man muss an seiner seite stehen
oder gibt es sogar noch mehr eine
konkrete diplomatische idee
möglicherweise die alles voranbringen
könnte hansjörg was weißt du darüber
aber die idee ist offensichtlich eine
europäische idee das heißt die drei
leben dass ich hier bin ich wieder fit
premier polens ist ja auch noch dabei
die reifen im auftrag als symbol europas
und wollen auch ein hilfspaket für die
kleinen ein aufbau verkehrt für die
ukraine dort vorstellen das ist also
letztlich eine riesige ohren und
trotzdem ist es natürlich
anerkennenswert dass diese
regierungschefs sich selbst in gefahr
begeben machen wir uns nichts vor jetzt
mit dem zug durch die ukraine zu weisen
das dauert nicht nur sehr lange sondern
es ist natürlich auch die chance für
russische truppen diesem zug auch
anzugreifen deswegen auch die große der
einhaltung dieses vorbild dabei war ich
bin hier in warschau eigentlich gewesen
um ein interview mit der moral wird
gegen den polnischen premier zu führen
und hatte immer wieder dem hinweis ist
kann sein dass etwas dazwischen kommt
nun wissen wir was dazwischen gekommen
dass die delegation hat sich doch mal
die einzig sinnvolle lösung oder der
einzig sinnvolle weg ist wohl dass die
richtigen job in südostpolen betroffene
haben am flughafen und sind dann dort in
einem zug eingeschrieben werden dann
über lemberg bis nach kiel wird es
sieben acht neun stunden party meilen
und vermutlich befinden sie sich jetzt
wenn wir hier sprechen gerade auch in
diesen zucker meine lange fahrt vor
sicher erweist details was in einem tag
geplant ist ein treffen mit seinen ski
steht an aber es sind ja auch schwierige
umstände dort drei spitzenpolitiker die
im krisengebiet reisen drei eu-politiker
die natürlich auch gewisse
sicherheitsvorkehrungen benötigen weißt
du irgendwelche details setzen wie das
ablaufen könnte
funktioniert die geheimhaltung
ausgesprochen gut das einzige was jetzt
eben bekannt geworden dass das um mittag
herum zum ländern passiert hat das heißt
aber immer noch sechs stunden fahrt bis
nach dir wie dort und hier dann eben aus
dem zug raus und dann zum treffen mit
mir und demokratischen präsidenten wie
das genau ablaufen soll darf überhaupt
keine vorstellungen offensichtlich hält
auch keine für seite ausgesprochen nicht
und man kann es verstehen denn damit wir
mussten natürlich ungern sagen dass ich
nicht hierher dann plötzlich gleich vier
oder fünf oder sechs politiker der
ukraine und der europäischen daten haben
gerade schon über diesen eigentlich so
wunderbaren archiven gedanken gesprochen
der fahren einfach diese männer hin
diese regierungschefs und stellen sich
sozusagen sprichwörtlich den bomben den
raketen entgegen für einen moment das
erinnert an die noch mutigeren bilder
vor allen dingen aus der ost und süd
ukraine wo die menschen einfach auf die
straße gegangen sind unbewaffnet mit den
fahnen der ukraine und sich den panzern
entgegengestellt haben
solche gedanken aktuell in der politik
tatsächlich eine rolle oder hältst du
das für naiv also einfach dorthin
einfach sich an die seite von selen ski
zu stellen ich finde dass in
faszinierenden gedanken und worten ich
komme mir dabei überhaupt nicht ich bin
unglaublich beeindruckt an den mut diese
politiker werden sauer über sich heute
und morgen als ich das bestätigt bekam
man muss allerdings auch wissen dass in
polen diese reise eine vorgeschichte
2008 sind die russen in georgien
eingefallen und zu dem zeitpunkt hat
damals lech kaczynski der damalige
polnische präsident eine ähnliche reise
gemacht hat die bayerischen
regierungsvertreter mitgenommen und ist
bis nach tiflis in nachgerade gefangen
hat dort 450.000 menschen vor dem
georgischen parlament eine rede gehalten
in der er und das muss man sich auf der
zunge zergehen lassen wenn der davor
warnte dass wir möglicherweise nur der
anfang ist das nicht so ganz leicht die
ukraine sein könnte danach das baltikum
und dann womöglich mein heimatland polen
sogar gesagt das ich gegeben hat das ist
etwas woran die polen hier sehr genau
erinnern und das damals hier inzwischen
verstorbene präsident lech kaczynski
wer recht hat und wer vorausschauend
eine letzte frage noch ein dich hansjörg
werden gerade festgestellt es ist gar
kein gedanke diese symbolwirkung und
auch dieses schutzschild ja schon fast
da stellt sich auch die frage meinst du
es werden weitere politiker diesem
vorbild folgen also kannst du dir
vorstellen dass wir irgendwann
beispielsweise urlaubs im kriegsgebiet
sehen ist das eine inspiration für
andere
ich glaube möglich ist es für alle
letztlich muss man aber immer noch
einmal bedenkt jetzt eine eben
delegation die dort findet und jetzt
nach und nach jeder der der
regierungschef der eu also alle
mitgliedsstaaten einmal pro woche dort
dann auf das wäre es hätte eine
unglaublich wichtige hier wäre
wahnsinnig wichtige geste der
solidarität
selbstverständlich muss man auch
überlegen ob die politiker nicht an
anderen stellen machen dass darüber
verhandlungen könnten man dann konkret
der ukraine auch wirklich helfen kann
eins muss man ja erst auch noch einmal
feststellen in diesem fall ist
ausdrücklich die hilfe angeboten wird
eine wiederaufbau und militärischer
hilfe oder ähnlichem ich gehört auch
nicht die rede danke hans jörg viele
walser bild chefreporter in warschau
heute haben sich die regierungschefs von
polen von slowenien und von tschechien
auf den weg gemacht in die kriegs
hauptstadt nach kiew um ihre solidarität
auszudrücken ihrem kollegen ihrem
präsidenten der ukraine wladimir
selensky ihm beizustehen und haben diese
gefährliche reise auf sich genommen